ich muss mir noch vorstellen mein name
ist weg messe findet miss athletischer
geahnt
wer leute
die sich in welcher beauftragt
ich bin auf der suche nach einem auto
aber nicht als ein auto
willkommen zum bild grand prix der
schnellste rennwagen aller pisten katze
an wenn eine mission so gefährlich ist
vertrauen die weltbesten spion
das war echt knapp einem absoluten
gewinner team habt ihr gehört
gewinnerteam ich werde nämlich auch
gebraucht
amerikaner
also ich habe auf der agenten schule
wirklich von der pike auf gelernt wie
man mit ganoven bösewichtern und welt
zerstören umgeht
ich hoffe ihr habt das auch frauen na
klar ich hab sogar ganz fleißig geübt
seht euch mal den abschleppwagen da die
sim-karte kann ich auch aber
die rechnung aber ohne mich zu machen
leute denn da wohl ich bin erst
explosive stimmung mcqueen darf das
rennen nicht gewinnen
cars 2 ab jetzt im kino
campra markiert jetzt nach einem
bayerischen zeit aus mir wahnsinn da
gehe ich gleich zugreifen platteln
airbus